é possível quebrar vidro com laser azul
pessoal de quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos mas 1 bilhão e hoje nós
vamos fazer mais um episódio de nossa
série é possível e vocês perguntaram
muito nos comentários
é possível quebrar vidro colégio pedro
ii elétrico porque um copo e as dos
copos por aí distribuindo muito que o
assunto está proibido o falsete nós
saímos já vi muita gente fazer isso ok
software não resultasse não partiram o
vidro eu acho que vou tentar com minha
voz não temos de ficar mais profundo
vidrinhos avançaram descobriu que era
pedir ajuda é uma coisa importante que
se faça isso ajuda a evitar um piloto de
corrida que eu adoro e antónio félix da
costa e outro a participar nesta corrida
é preciso 20 votos mesmo muito voto
muito voto e eu preciso dessas três
basta clicar aqui no link em baixo aqui
na descrição o primeiro link deixou a
página e tudo até abaixo e clique em
votar com o facebook e depois vai para
ser uma lista com vários pilotos e aí
vocês escolhem antónio félix da costa e
depois clicar em dubai por ser um botão
a dizer e roubos
iam vocês vão dar o voto façam isso
vamos todos ajudar em sua memória de 2º
c o site é confiável é tudo confiável e
portanto vou ter uma vez obrigado pela
vossa ajuda e já sabe que só tem muito a
equipe neste vídeo é porque isso é muito
importante isso não foi inscrito aqui no
canal escrever mãos que carrega em si
nem prefeito diz vídeo é parceiro muito
vídeo novo agora ia gostar muito má
porque eu tô um pouco doente não
gostasse bem grossa mas perto nosso
problema olha só que eu comprei ai nem
sei o que isto é não só do filme uma
lojinha do chinês que eu comprei algumas
coisas preto e este é uma dessas coisas
mas também estão lá mas sim netplay dor
mas não parece playdom porque o texto
dele é muito estranho aí está que é
preto porque comprei uma cor escura
mesmo proteger colégio e comprei um
veículo passa flexible espanhol flexível
e clay água em lei e notou que ficou no
mucho layton e eu espero um pouco tempo
não eu pisar sobre uma senha pessoal e
eu não sei como é que sabe pois é que
tem me utilizado aí ele começou
é muito estranha mistura eu vou tentar
colocar isso tudo aqui dentro
olha isso e buscar mais para trás até o
leste possui
eu estou muito estranho até mesmo fly
estão offline
essa textura muito estranho sério e tem
uma textura úmida mas que não olha as
mãos e vamos fazer aqui um texto vou
fazer uma bom nível disse ela salta em
321 vai o ovo não é mesmo
como é que eu nunca descobri instante
olha isso eu gosto de brincar como a
linha amarela está a ficar mais duro
olha só
mas vamos lá então a parte importante do
pessoal que é testar o nosso coisa com
esta sim nunca esqueço óculos de
proteção para a segurança sempre
mangueira para lá só em 321 vai jantar
de aproximação da fumaça da queimada
está aqui o pessoal apoiador não queimou
mas esta está a queimar a colheita fica
bem preto em xerém tira mesmo bem serem
olha só como ficou o toque bem queimado
não se conseguem ver
i ai então um tóxico no mês ficou mesmo
em cinza
dora só ficou bem louco mas agora vão
experimentar com esta máxima e preta só
vai ser só o barulho para lá 31 marcando
muito mais sim é só fumaça taleban
queimado letra um túnel passando vai
assistindo marca tentar que fosse um
circo olha esse queimado aqui sim o iiko
só que eu comprei na lojinha do chinês
olha só quem compra uma caixa de
fósforos mas esta não é uma casa fosse
normal né essa é uma caixa de fósforos
gigante olha só o tamanho do palito para
isso é muito grande e vamos fazer uma
coisa que já fizemos semelhante mas com
foco nos mais pequenos que tentar
ascender a caixa também está a ser muito
observa
isso é muito muito forte ea tv empresas
com elástico o que isto vai dar muito
jeito vamos usar simples diga vou
colocar aqui esforços e vamos tentar se
deus todos à distância mas primeiro vou
testar 13 2 11 vai
mas político law se deu muito bem é isso
de uma chapa muito alta e como vocês
puderam ver a chama do forte foi muito
alta imaginem-se cento fosse só vocês
estão aqui o edital
321 vai ler ver se os fósforos vôlei já
ficou rotulado como explodir isso comigo
tudo isso não apaga uma tocha por aí
só estamos aqui mais gráfico tem uma
tocha
isso é uma coisa mas com este teste é
para ficar chegar muito podre não chega
fácil muito fácil aguentar assim sendo
muito malandro é mais uma vez lembra o
pessoal não façam isso em casa nunca é
esse é bem perigoso aqui mas eu como sou
assim e eu sujei mais um quarto
a próxima coisa que eu vou estar aqui
você elásticos pra eu tenho aqui muito
elástico essa muito elástico e minha
idéia era ficar mutiladas e que depois
passaram a ser entre os que vencemos bem
todos não rebentam eu vou tentar aqui
com eu acho que vocês vão perceber que
leis eleitorais só taxando o atacou
muito e agora o texto quer fazer essa
parte po 50 elastic ver o que acontece
eu vou fazer isso é que eu vou tentar
desde lá se é porque demora muito tempo
a fazer só aguenta e coisas que eram que
eu faço eu tive experiências novas ou
coisas fáceis quero ver e que nunca
conseguiram fazer em casa eu posso fazer
aqui então comenta e todas as medidas
possíveis e eu faço para lá só em 321
vai tratar sem fumaça já o asa tentará
de tudo mas vai ter um só tom estão a
tentar todos os elásticos mas não muito
porque nos bateram no meu pulso vamos
por aqui vigora no chão porque está
ainda a proteína mesa é pesado ea
próxima experiência pessoal acho que
vocês vão gostar que tentar rebentar da
ual banco é ele pra quem não sabe que
isto é equipar um balão gigante quase
indestrutível que eu quero fazer é
encher mundo
o seguinte até ficar uma bola gigante e
depois apontaram dois e ver o que
acontece e eu vou sair tem que preencher
um gol bobo eu nunca vou falar uma bomba
bom olha só atacar uma bolinha só tática
muito grande ou aprová lo
o zapata muito grande até conseguimos
correr atrás da bola
olha é isso eu ainda vou encher mais é
que isto muito grande isso faz o dele no
braço por muito grande que chega chega
sua vez lançou também do amor banda
moleque tá muito grande e agora nós
estávamos na fila ok vou deixar o bolo
aqui e eu vou tentar clube está
assistindo ao toque que ver o rapaz
encontra o vovõ em 321 vai roubar um dos
protocolos é eu acho que não pode porque
aquilo é translúcida então você passa
por dentro e nem chega a queima então
vamos tentar outra forma e vou tentar
usar um x-acto ela só na empresa do pai
eu sou eu né fiz barulho e poder do
acusado e que puderam ver não é possível
destruir lobão com laser
a próxima coisa que nós vamos testar
aqui é uma coisa que eu tô bem curioso a
nossa experiência também contra uma
caixinha e essa é uma daquelas caixinhas
tem que mandar é muito fina ó é bem
frágil ela também era e eu sei que a
máquina a laser que consegue fazer um
design outro o nosso nome aqui e as
coisas também quer mostrar que é
possível fazer um quiz com isto é não
sair mas não está 321 vai ser a que vai
queimar uma bandeira
sim eu acho que não faço nada mesmo já
está sem fumaça só está sem fumaça e
queimou foi aí que meu medo era que
mudar se eu ficar deixa um dia em cada
linha eu acho que consegui fazer aqui um
desenho assim estojo vai só faltou
conseguir já fiz um olho já fiz um olho
o que eu já fiz o outro olho e agora
vamos fazer a boca a boca vai ser muito
mais difícil mas eu vou conseguir diz a
lucas que conseguiu fazer um filme olha
aí consegui fazer um treino aqui na
nossa mãe dele funcionou
imagine se uma vez mais o tempo consegui
fazer isso muito mais rápido mas pelo
menos já deu pra fazer isso
olha aí de cima e agora pessoal próxima
coisa que nós vamos fazer é não escolher
a nossa pergunta é possível por vidro
com laser pela star stop ea estrela um
resultado que mantém a sua parte acho
que não vai partir com laser contra
vidro em 321 vai
o ouro foi muito acho que tem que usar
os jogos agora isso que ser lá na frente
e ainda reflexo do quarto aqui do lado
olha aí tem um brasileiro entrar na
porta a qualquer só tenho uma espécie de
silver tail que eu vou colocar sobre por
dentro do copo é que isso vai acontecer
assim que você vai passar entre o hotel
a chuva que a maré se é verdade o que
vai aquecer o corpo e tomar um copo que
vocês acham eu não sei não sei mas
embora lá 31 mai o liceu foi ainda pra
que eu acho que deixaram no dia seguinte
o tempo eu acho que o copo vai aquecido
tanto que vai partir hoje para isso
precisa da ajuda da minha melhor né
vamos votar melhor não vou subir um
pouco mas eu acho que o senhor certa
foi só eu acho que vai partir o vidro só
podem ver o lecce está tocar diretamente
no vidro e não passa a se inverter se
isso resultar é muito bom é muito bom
mesmo
o cap só vou fazer uma pausa do caribe
está aqui ok pra quem tá muito q ta ta
muito quem a fez ser muito rápido também
frio já eu vou ficar aqui seu backup mas
não só tem um público muito pequeno e eu
acho que isto dê certo portanto eu acho
que nossa pergunta está respondida não é
possível por vidro colégio simplesmente
porque o vidro translúcido e tomás e não
consegue entrar em concentração no vidro
é não ser que seja um vídeo especial
neto em um vídeo mais curto assim mas
tem mais como funciona mas eu sei que eu
tenho é que os copos quer testar outra
experiência que é tentar pedir um copo
com voz
o u1 isso quebrou muito viu desfilou
muitoooo muito lembra mesmo só se
quiserem que eu faça um vídeo a disputar
esta técnica ea tentar achar a forma
perfeita porque um copo com voz comentei
muito porque eu vou fazer eu quero mesmo
fazer mas só comentará e deixarem muito
laquê neste ano então é isso só vou
ficar porque o espírito é tenham estado
aqui o resultado dessa experiência e já
sabe investir muito aqui no espírito
isso não foi inscrito e inscreva-se no
canal ser exigido muito mesmo e é isso
que vai até a próxima